um have you seen Jimmy Fallon do this uh
what's in the box
oh heck no have you I've seen you've
done before I'm not there like like yeah
Mystery Box challenge on social you know
nah we're not doing that
no we're not doing that that's a snake
no we're not doing that yeah listen
that's a snake yeah
I do not trust chat I don't trust I'll
do it stop no everybody's gonna do it
but there's nothing there's nothing
living like that okay yeah that's what
you tell me no I guarantee you jet Kenny
Kenny gets to go first yes you are come
on man stop
so you just
reach in here I'm not going first come
on come on man
play along let's go and just tell us
what tell us what it is
[Music]
do it man it's not alive man do it come
on man it's a wimp
what does it feel like
[Music]
hard-boiled egg uh that that is
incorrect
can I see what it is yeah no would you
like to take one more try at it maybe
it's easier just feel a little more
that's an egg man yep
that is an egg
it is a
it is a kiwi about it okay see and you
were afraid to touch a keyword feel the
top of that
how did you think that was an egg no but
I didn't feel I thought this one see
that wasn't that bad that wasn't so bad
this is soft come on man
Chuck give me a shot it is Shaq's turn
Shaquille Illinois totally going
oh chicken wings
[Laughter]
plus barbecue barbecue chicken
oh look very nice
because it starts with a K okay
all right and now
nice work big fella I gotcha
um and now but chuckster
what could this possibly be Chuck our
plans
[Music]
[Laughter]
hurt you
[Music]
hey man
y'all crazy
[Laughter]
you want to come out here
let's see
[Music]
[Laughter]